une famille face à onze ans de questions
les proches d'anne sophie girollet ont
vécu aujourd'hui l'ouverture du procès
de jacques martin l'homme est accusé de
séquestration suivi du meurtre de la
jeune fille âgée de 21 ans 2005 un
moment douloureux mais nécessaire mes
clients aborde ce procès avec attentes
11 ans depuis qu'anne sophie est parti
mais avec l' angoisse aussi de tout ce
qui pourra se dire dans ces prochains
jours d'audience je pense que le
soulagement pourra être là dès lors que
monsieur jacky martens parlera et pourra
exprimer ce qui s'est passé pourra faire
un récit des faits parce que pour
l'instant on n'a rien que des
dénégations des attentes pour le moment
déçu face à la famille l'accusé âgé de
54 ans a clamé son innocence cet après
midi combatif il a continué à dénoncer
comme depuis le début de la sphère la
profonde injustice dont il se dit
victime il l'état d'esprit de jacky
martens est très simple il est innocent
des crimes dont on l'accuse
répondre aux questions qui vont déposer
par la cour d'assises depuis le début de
ce dossier depuis sa mise en examen
depuis son incarcération il a toujours
contesté de bec et ongles avoir une
responsabilité dans cette de nombreuses
questions restent encore en suspens dès
demain experts et témoins tenteront
d'apporter de nouveaux éléments aux
jurés jacky martens encourt la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité